schauen sie sich mal dieses gemälde hier
an
das bild hat der sohn eines imbisses aus
einem dorf in schleswig-holstein im
nachlass seines vaters entdeckt ist das
wirklich der erste fang doch das
hamburger auktionshaus dächer
versteigert das am ersten september und
es ist das vielleicht früheste gemälde
des großen vincent van gogh der besitzer
des bildes hofft jetzt auf millionen ja
und bei mir im studio ist walter straten
weiter ist es denn jetzt wirklich der
erste fang doch sei es spricht einiges
dafür dass es ein sehr frühes gemälde
ist von vincent van gogh es gibt
technische untersuchung zum beispiel der
farbpigmente die deuten darauf hin dass
es genau in dieser zeit etwa um 1880
gemalt ist
man kann spekulieren erst mal geht es um
die frage ist es überhaupt anfangen doch
da gehen die meinungen auseinander das
van-gogh-museum in amsterdam die letzte
instanz sozusagen als bisher nicht als
eigenhändig anerkannt aber es gibt hier
ich zeig mal eine menge gutachten die
für dieses gemälde sprechen ja also es
könnte sehr gut sein dass es eines der
ersten bilder ist dass vincent van gogh
gewarnt hat und wenn es das es ist es
dann die entdeckung des jahres dann ist
zumindest eine große entdeckung ja das
kann man so sagen es ist eine kopie
genaugenommen vincent van gogh hat sich
an einem niederländischen meister des 17
jahrhunderts jakob von häusler
orientiert hat ein bild von ihm kopiert
zumindest sehr ähnlich nachgemalt das
hammer sehr häufig getan um zu üben um
zu lernen sich an den großen alten
meistern zu orientieren das wird alles
sehr gut passen es gibt ein problem bei
diesem bild das ist die signatur fast
jeder weiß vincent van gogh hat seine
farbenfrohen späteren gemälde mit
vincent signiert also mit seinem
vornamen hier steht van gogh drauf sein
nachname
das ist meines wissens das einzige
gemälde mit seinem nachnamen
auch dafür gibt es eine erklärung
nämlich er hat sich beschwert bei seinem
bruder theo der in paris lebt als
kunsthändler dass die franzosen seinen
namen van gogh nicht richtig aussprechen
können und man möge doch jetzt immer ihn
als vincent präsentieren so wie er sich
selbst auf diesem gemälde die welt sehen
auch signierte
so gesehen spricht dass eigentlich diese
seltsame signatur spricht auch wieder
für die echtheit ein fälscher hätte ja
dann logischerweise vincent genommen
weil das ist der gängige name und dann
wäre es vielleicht eher verkäuflich
gewesen also so ist eine etwas kuriose
signatur vielleicht einen anhaltspunkt
dass es ein echter und zwar sehr frühe
fernkorn ist und wie viel wäre dann
dieses gemälde wert wirklich millionen
naja so das ist natürlich ein bisschen
zocken
die absegnung ich sagte dass das van
gogh museums fehlt der käufer geht ein
gewisses risiko ein der staat preis bei
der auktion wird 500.000 euro sein das
ist schon eine menge holz würde ich mal
sagen wenn es sich am ende bestätigt
wird wenn es vielleicht doch noch das
okay das van gogh museums bekommt dann
ist es natürlich schon einige millionen
wert aber das risiko bleibt bestehen
mal schauen ob sich sammler und auch
spekulations freudige käufer finden die
sich dann vielleicht doch gegenseitig in
die höhe treiben die familie hofft auf
ein bis zwei millionen euro
wie gesagt ab 500.000 geht die option
denn los und wie oft kommt so was vor
dass man auf dem dachboden oder im
keller noch solche kunstschätze findet
es kommt vor also gut nicht jeder hat
heutzutage dachboden es ist selten dass
muss man sagen viele leute finden was
auf dem dachboden oder im keller kommen
mit großen hoffnungen in dem museum oder
zu einem experten und er sagt denn es
ist entweder eindruck wertloses bild
also das ist wirklich was ganz
besonderes ist das content stand äußerst
selten vor